time is a funny thing  one day you're a little girl running  fast toward an unknowable future and  then suddenly you're an adult I'm sure  of who you are and what you're doing I  know that I've let you down the past I'd  like to make it up to you now please  help me you want to go back to a time  with things ring simple again everybody  looking at venom I'm going home I'm out  we hold her from no you're not you're  coming with me to the after-party  hey hi how come you talk to me like we  didn't ride our bikes every day when we  were eight or not eight more you being  here this numbers in such a bad thing  don't you have somewhere else that you  can be hi your nose looks funny shut up  you shut up you want romance  earth-shattering a life change shapes  should be come on  under garage  [Music]  [Music]  you